tu sais où les dents mais on est dans
une carrière d'avocat
quelque chose d'horrible va bien posé en
costume mondiaux
tout le monde ici connaît beaucoup trop
la route la plus hantée des états unis
pourquoi l'homme crée-t-il des mythes
pour ensuite les détruire
je suis content que tu sois là c'était
un projet pour notre cour la
construction et la destruction du mythe
moderne il ya trois semaines on a
commencé à faire des cauchemars vraiment
vraiment saisissant
parle-moi de ses rêves le rêve est
fragmenté
est ce que tu sais où elle emmène dans
une clairière de buck un trône et puis
je me réveille je fais des cauchemars
dis moi tout ce que tu sais chacun de
nous fait un rêve en lien avec une
légende urbaine
elles ont maudit la route on est tous
devenus somnambule les terres ont été
maudite par une main anonyme et sont
désormais la route du diable macao trop
d devenue la route du diable non
renvoyez s'attend en enfer reste avec
moi
et tu effrayer